نيجي لاخبار المشاهير في قصص المشاهير
بمصر تحديدا ما بتخلص ومن المشاهير
للاعلاميين واحنا مكملين فبعد ما دخل رجل
الاعمال المصري نجيب سويرس في سيجال مع
اعلاميين مصريين بعد تعليقه على صوره
مزيفه ساخره لعدد من الاعلاميين يدقون
الطبول نشر صوير الصوره معدله من حساب
مغرب مجهول بتجمع ست اعلاميين على راسهم
عمرو اديب بيحملوا طبله ليقوم نجيب سويرس
بتغريدها مره اخرى على حسابه وكتب عليها
في واحد ناقص واكيد يا جماعه عمرو اديب ما
سكت وقتها واعتبر انه اعاده تغريد نجيب
سويرس للصوره بتحمل اشاره مباشره واتهام
له ولا زملاءه كمان بالتطبيق لا يرد عمرو
اديب بتعليق على تغريده سواراس احنا ما
كسبناش ان التطبيل قد ما انت كسبت من
تطبيلك يا نجيب جايز تطويلنا كان له اصوات
انما تطويلك كان له ابراج ودولارات
ويخساره وعجبي عموما هيك بلشت القصه بس
الجديده بالموضوع انه تغريده تغريده
انتشرت بتحمل خبر اقامه سوي راس حفله
اعتذار من الاعلاميين على الاساءه الاساءه
لهم رجع طبعا الاخذ والرد في هذا الموضوع
بس سال احد المغردين حول رئيس سواراس في
نبا اعتذار ولا الاعلاميين خلال الحفل
الخاص في الجونه فرنسا سؤال كلام فارغ